can you be default aggressive and
relaxed in jiu-jitsu okay yeah this
seems like two opposing things that you
can't do at the same time but the actual
fact is yes you can and you should
so you want your maneuvers to be
aggressive but you don't want to be
using a bunch of strength to execute the
maneuvers right you want to aggressively
escape your opponent's position before
your opponent gets settled therefore you
don't have to use strength you can use
relax it you can relax you can you can
be proactive same thing with defending a
submission attempt you want to defend
that submission attempt aggressively
before this submission attempt gets
settled in you want to move aggressively
again I'm not talking about strength and
spazzing I'm talking about moving
aggressively before your opponent moves
and get ahead of them on their loop when
you get ahead of them on their hooter
loop they're gonna have issues with you
and so yeah absolutely you can be
default aggressive and at the same time
you can be relaxed and you should that
should be your goal do you sometimes
have to use strength in jujitsu yes you
do yes you do sometimes you got a power
out of something
why did you the reason you had to power
out or something is cuz you were too
late because you weren't moving
aggressively enough you weren't moving
quickly enough and then you got a power
out of something gotta call all those
hands claw that guillotine off your neck
you know I'm saying you want to get Agia
telling someone they're clawing your
fingers away from their neck yes yeah so
when that happens that person was late
and and now they're clawing they're
resorting to strength or resorting to
panic clawing at your fingers you
sometimes don't usually doesn't even
matter
I can claw it doesn't matter good I like
that sense of panic that I feel what
they're clawing yeah I'm sure you do you
really so that's what that's what it is
and by the way this is true in life as
well right you like if if you are
maneuvering correctly correctly as a
leader you don't have to get aggressive
at people
because they're doing what they're
supposed to be doing yeah you don't have
to be
you shouldn't have to yell if you have
to yell as a boss guess what your your
intent wasn't followed your plan wasn't
understood there's so many mistakes that
you made if you're yelling as a leader
do you never have to yell yeah so
sometimes you can yell because you got
to make sure you get that emotional
point across sometimes you got to make
sure that someone real like someone
doesn't seem to realize that the mistake
they made is severe enough that that it
warrants yelling and therefore it
doesn't matter to them
because their dad yelled in their whole
life well so if you're not yelling they
don't get it so can you couldn't can you
run to that cake problem occasionally
occasionally very occasionally very very
rarely should you run into that
situation because if you're doing the
right job being default aggressive as a
leader you should be in situations where
you never have to yell because your
people because you people understand
what it is that they're supposed to be
doing they understand why they're
supposed to be doing it they understand
what the plan is they understand what
the contingencies were they understand
what the what the intent that you had
was they understand this the way that
this fits strategically into the
situation they understand all those
things and if they understand all those
things then they're gonna do the right
thing and if they don't if they
understand all those things and they
still do something that that doesn't
make sense
well me maybe they do deserve get yelled
at but again all the first person our
check is myself and say obviously to
make this clear enough mm-hmm so yes
relax harder so yelling is to leading as
using strength is to jujitsu someone
gotta do it everyone yeah everyone so or
if you lay maybe you'll act on your
technique earlier you're gonna kind of
but think about this you hurt your
stamina yeah he's your strength right
yeah when I yell at you because
something went wrong you're my
subordinate when I yell at you
I paid a little price for that too yeah
cuz I better be important
and I better really think about it cuz I
didn't do anything to build our
relationship in a positive manner by
yelling to you right didn't do anything
yeah just like you didn't improve your
jujitsu just see chronologies or or
really you I guess you improved your
situation for a moment right because you
were safe but now you're more tired just
like if I yelled at you to do something
and you get it because you real you know
you were
okay we'll find when you yelled at
anymore someone's gonna do this the
thing that he told me to do that it's
temporary fix it's a temporary fix yeah
you know how like JP will say aggressive
it isn't or default aggressive isn't
towards people it's towards making
things happen so like so dude it's the
same thing so it's like I don't regress
Li like it's an it in a way you kind of
can narrow it down to the timing thing
it's like it's like it's either taking
action or hesitating kind of thing so
you just don't really hesitate you can
lay back if that's part of the strategy
and stuff like that
you can relax once for the strategy but
it's about making things happen like
what are you trying to make things
happen timing wise so you know like you
have a thing Tim Ferriss asked what is
the disrespect remember you asked me
that
what's the disrespect oh you're do they
you made up but yeah you made up the
terminology as well so the disrespect is
as basically at when a guy pulls guard
or you're in a guard scenario it's
actually not even a guard scenario yet
it's like you essentially treat that
person like they don't even have a
garden like the guard doesn't even exist
that's how little respect you have for
the guard and then you just pass but
when you kind of think about it when I
think about it when you've done it to me
three times you have it is literally
that so before I can establish any kind
of position to establish guard you're
just wrong just yeah you're past it
you're done you know you don't even
consider the guard you know what's weird
is is where people get confused on this
though is they think oh so you're saying
move faster yeah right that's the weird
thing
yeah it is it's not it's I'm sure I'll
think of this at a later time but it's
not about moving faster it's about
moving more aggressively yeah it's not
faster it's like being proactive and
being aggressive and and shutting down
the situation before before it even
becomes the situation that you know
what's going to become you know so if
you take well you said like like if you
take taking action and hesitation you
take those two it's basically your
narrowing the hesitation down to zero
it's possible just literally what it is
yeah just take action and again you can
relax
you can wait but it's not hesitation
waiting it's waiting that's like more
like being patient or waiting for a very
specific reason you can do
all those things but there's no
hesitation that's what I think that is
and then obviously it's gonna vary this
is something you hear over and over and
over again in combat leadership
philosophies like doing something now is
better than waiting I mean doing
something doing something that's pretty
good right now is infinitely better than
doing something that's great in two days
yeah the aggressive make something
happen yeah like that is so important
can you overdo it yes you can can you
make stupid decisions because you rushed
yes you can
is there a dichotomy in this absolutely
there is the that's there's a dichotomy
in every part of it so in every type of
leadership there's a dichotomy and
jujitsu right there's a doctor because
if I just rush to a situation well that
might be the situation that you want to
be to rush it gave me the opening the
trap yeah so it's like you know when
you're like helping your friend move and
then you get like three four other
friends you know and everyone's waiting
around to be like okay where do we start
okay where do we put you know where do
we start who's starting first kind of
thing
the default aggressive guy he's just
gonna start moving stuff yeah and that
seems like okay that's like a little
light-hearted scenario but that's real
that's what I would run into it you know
when there's a bunch of people and we're
all capable of making the decision it
kind of paralyzes everyone because oh
this is so true it that scenario that
you're talking about it happens over and
over and over again in the business
world it happens over and over again on
the battlefield it happens on the
training field where there's a bunch of
people no one's taking leadership
position yeah like all it takes is
someone to say hey we're moving this
over here to get all the stuff off the
truck right now boom guys are like okay
cool we'll make it happen
yeah like your oil rig scenario the main
exact same thing yeah and if your
default aggressive meaning that's your
default that's the that's your zero you
hear that hundred percent then you're
just handling business right your whole
life until you take it too far yeah and
you're trying to run stuff that other
people might have a better vision of
what to do like if I might be if I'm
only moving for the first time ever mmm
on our moving team and I come in I'm
like hey guess what hey we're gonna
start getting this to heavy stuff and
you're like eh actually
that's not a good idea yeah we should do
this we should get this stuff in here
into the truck first or whatever right
because you've been doing it longer so
even though it's got to be your default
mode again there's a dichotomy you can
push it too far better keep your eyes
open